jetzt Achim Post für die SPD frau
Präsidentin bisher hat diese
lebendige Debatte viel
Dissens gezeigt das ist gut so das ist
legitim das gehört dazu sie hat an einer
Stelle gezeigt dass die Einschätzung
über die Bedeutung dieses Gipfels
ähnlich hoch ist das ist nicht irgendein
Gipfel
das ist nicht irgendein Krisengipfel das
wäre eine Untertreibung
die Regierungschefs die Staats- und
Regierungschefs haben vor sich
krisengebirge mit sich überlappenden
Krisen
und da kann ich nur sagen das steht in
keinem Drehbuch da steht in keinem
Koalitionsvertrag dafür gibt es keine
Blaupause
dafür braucht man andere Dinge
Vernunft
Pragmatismus
Lösungsorientierung Handlungsfähigkeit
und einen starken Bundeskanzler und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin
froh dass wir einen starken
Bundeskanzler haben der nach diesen
Maßstäben handelt und auch auf diesem
Gipfel handeln wird
und ich finde dass die Bundesregierung
liefert
das kann ich überhaupt nicht als
lächerlich einschätzen oder sind 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr lächerlich nein sie sind es
nicht oder sind drei entlastungspakete
in Höhe von 95 Milliarden Euro
lächerlich nein sie sind es nicht oder
sind die angekündigten 200 Milliarden
Euro zur Entlastung bei den
explodierenden Energiepreisen lächerlich
nein liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie
sind es nicht
und diese Bundesregierung
liefert auch politisch sie hat ihren
Beitrag dazu geleistet ihren großen
Beitrag dazu geleistet dass Europa eben
nicht gespalten ist wie sich er Putin
das vorgestellt hat sondern geeint ist
bei den Sanktionen die schwierig sind
aber richtig sind und notwendig sind
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und bei
der Politik die sie jetzt betreibt und
die sie auf dem Gipfel weiter betreiben
wird Europa steht zusammen Deutschland
agiert im europäischen Kontext und im
Kontext der NATO und das ist richtig so
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und
Herr Merz wenn sie mit ihrer durchaus
berechtigten heftigten heftigen zum Teil
fundamentalen Kritik an der
EU-Kommission an ihrer Parteikollegin
aus der CDU Deutschlands Frau von der
Leyen oder auch an der Christdemokratin
aus Malta Roberta mezzo leider
Präsidentin des Europäischen Parlaments
Kritik üben das ist völlig in Ordnung
wenn sie das machen dann habe ich eine
Frage
bisher habe ich gedacht bisher habe ich
gedacht bisher habe ich gedacht es gibt
in Europa es gibt bei diesen großen
Parteien bei den großen Volksparteien in
Deutschland Konsens das ist richtig ist
die Demokratie in Europa zu stärken das
glaube ich weiter gibt es auch Konsens
die Demokratien in Europa zu stärken
daran habe ich mittlerweile meine
Zweifel reicht es nicht aus dass wir
einen Orban haben und seine kompanionen
reicht es nicht aus dass wir eine
e-liberale Demokratie haben und andere
in der Europäischen Union muss auch
jetzt noch Schweden und Italien und im
nächsten Jahr vielleicht Spanien dazu
kommen und warum können die dazu kommen
weil Manfred Weber der Chef der EVP der
Türöffner ist für Bündnisse von
Christdemokraten konservativen mit
Populisten Rechtspopulisten und
Postfaschisten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und und ich bin dankbar ich bin wirklich
dankbar dass der Vorsitzende der CSU
Markus Söder sehr deutlich gesagt hat
dass die CSU und auch eher persönlich
eine Brandmauer wollen zwischen diesen
ganz Rechtsaußen und demokratischen
Parteien von ihnen höre ich Herr März
gar nichts ein dröhnendes Schweigen das
ist alles das ist nicht genug
und wir brauchen jetzt zusätzlich
krisenreaktionsfähigkeiten die über den
Tag hinausgehen wir müssen
Zukunftsinvestitionen tätigen in
batteriezahlfertigung in erneuerbare
Energie in Impfstoffe und vieles andere
mehr dazu ist die Europäische Union in
der Lage und sie wird auf diesem Gipfel
weiter dazu in der Lage sein und wir
brauchen beides Vertiefung und
Erweiterung der Europäischen Union ja es
ist richtig dass wir mehr als
Entscheidungen brauchen in vielen
Bereichen aber es ist genauso richtig
die nächsten Schritte zu gehen bei der
Erweiterung der EU bei der Erweiterung
und den westlichen Balkan liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn auch das gehört zur Politik dazu
auch zur Politik in Europa man muss
zudem stehen was man versprochen hat die
Europäische Union Deutschland auch hat
2003 in Thessaloniki versprochen wenn
die Kriterien eingehalten werden können
die Mitglieder des westlichen Balkans
nach und nach Mitglied werden es ist
fast 20 Jahre her um das einzulösen wir
sollten damit anfangen auf diesem liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zusammengefasst es steht viel auf dem
Spiel
dieser Bundeskanzler diese
Bundesregierung dieser
Bundesfinanzminister dieser
Wirtschaftsminister und diese
Außenministerin werden dieser
Verantwortung gerecht denn wie gesagt
das wichtigste ist jetzt pragmatisches
Handeln Handlungsfähigkeit für
Deutschland und Europa schönen Dank
Achim Post war das für die SPD und sie
haben es gesehen der Bundeskanzler ist
doch noch mal zurückgekommen denn 15 Uhr
beginnt der Gipfel in Brüssel der hat er
dann doch noch ein bisschen Zeit hat
noch mal seinem Freund Achim Post
zugehört und ich glaube beim nächsten
reden würde auch noch mal zuhören
Alexander Dobrindt der landesgruppenchef
der CDU CSU und erste Stellvertreter von
Friedrich Merz in der Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
Herr Bundeskanzler wir warten seit
Wochen dass sie sich im Deutschen
Bundestag erklären wir haben sie
mehrfach schriftlich aufgefordert hier
im Deutschen Bundestag zur Lage der
Nation zu sprechen und eine
Regierungserklärung abzugeben dass sie
das heute getan haben das ist zu
begrüßen aber dass der Anlass dazu eben
nicht die Nöte die Sorgen die Ängste der
Bürger waren sondern ausschließlich der
Sitzungsplan in Brüssel das müssen sie
sich vorhalten lassen der Bundeskanzler
mit welcher Mission fahren Sie jetzt
eigentlich nach Brüssel in welcher Rolle
treten sie in Brüssel jetzt eigentlich
auf ich erwarte dabei überhaupt nicht
dass sie den Anspruch ihres
Parteivorsitzenden erfüllen der von der
Führungsmacht Deutschland gesprochen hat
aber ich erwarte dass sie den Anspruch
haben in Europa Orientierung zu geben
darum geht es in diesen Zeiten und
Deutschland hätte jetzt eine Blaupause
liefern können für eine wirksame
strompreisbremse für eine wirksame
gaspreisbremse in Europa sie tun es
gerade nicht Herr Bundeskanzler
die gaskommission hatte die
Vorschläge vorgelegt des verfehlen
weiterhin die Entscheidungen dazu dieser
Bundesregierung sie lassen die Menschen
in Unsicherheit das gibt keine
Orientierung in Europa sie hätten ein
klares Signal heute geben können an
Europa für solide und stabile Finanzen
in Wahrheit haben sie ein fatales Signal
von Schattenhaushalten nach Brüssel
gegeben sie haben heute hier kein
einziges Wort über die Finanzfragen die
in Brüssel anstehen verloren kein
einziges Wort Herr Bundeskanzler vor
wenigen Tagen haben sie allerdings beim
Parteikongress der europäischen
Sozialisten gerne darüber gesprochen
dass Europa Schulden Vergemeinschaftung
braucht mit welchem Signal gehen Sie
jetzt eigentlich nach Brüssel der
Bundeskanzler
und sie hätten auch ein deutliches
Signal geben können dass Deutschland
die Ukraine mit zusätzlichen modernen
schweren Waffen unterstützt sie hätten
eine gemeinsame Lieferung von westlichen
Kampfpanzern innerhalb der Europäischen
Gemeinschaft ermöglichen können seit
Monaten scheitert die Bereitschaft aus
europäischen Ländern diese Lieferungen
durchzuführen an der Zögerlichkeit
Deutschlands hier fehlt es an
Orientierung aus Deutschland in Europa
und liebe Kolleginnen
sehr geehrte Frau Hasselmann sie haben
hier davon gesprochen
in Richtung der
cdu/csu-fraktion wo sind sie in ihrer
Verantwortung das waren ihre Worte
liebe Frau Hasselmann weil sie sicher so
sehr für stärkere Waffenlieferungen
einsetzen ich will ihnen sagen wo unsere
Verantwortung ist 100 Milliarden
sonderschulden im Grundgesetz
ausschließlich für die Bundeswehr zur
Verfügung die sind deswegen entstanden
weil wir all ihre Versuche der
Zweckentfremdung dieser Gelder
verhindert haben da ist unsere
staatspolitische Verantwortung
Herr Dobrindt gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Bemerkung von Frau
Hasseler ja selbstverständlich bitte sie
haben das Wort
Herr Dobrindt weil sie das Ansprechen
und so tun als sei das eine große
staatspolitische Verantwortung gewesen
ich bin froh und dankbar dass sie
zugestimmt haben in der Tat aber ehrlich
gesagt war das auch meine Erwartung an
sie denn
wer vier
bundesverteidigungsminister:innen
gestellt hat in den letzten 16 Jahren
und die Bundeswehr so
runtergewirtschaftet hat wie sie das
gemacht haben
wir waren deshalb in der Situation zu
einem Sondervermögen greifen zu müssen
wie hätten Sie es denn sonst gemacht
warum haben sie diese Verantwortung in
den letzten 16 Jahren für die Bundeswehr
nicht wahrgenommen und ich kann mir
nicht verkneifen zu sagen warum waren
sie eigentlich so engstirnig
die kritische Infrastruktur die
Sicherheitsarchitektur die notwendigen
Investitionen in cybersicherheit und das
was notwendig ist zu verweigern wir
stehen da heute in einer großen
kritischen Situation und dem Thema zu
widmen das sehen wir durch die
Sabotageakte hier in Europa
indirekt haben sie gerade zugegeben dass
sie offensichtlich ein großes Interesse
daran hatten ein wesentlichen Teil
dieser 100 Milliarden unter ihren grünen
Ministerinnen und Minister Ministern
aufzuteilen und nicht in die Bundeswehr
zu investieren
genau das haben wir verhindert dass sie
diese Mittel anders verwenden das ist
für sie ein Rendezvous mit der Realität
ich kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen
dass ihnen das schwerfällt regierend ist
doch schwerer als moralisieren das ist
das was sie jetzt offensichtlich zu
Erkenntnis nehmen
und wäre die Lage ehrlicherweise nicht
ganz so ernst dann könnte man sich
mancher vollmundiger Sätze die ich in
den letzten Tagen von Ihnen und anderen
gehört habe auch auf ihrem Parteitag
durchaus auch mit Humor begleiten aber
die Lage ist nun mal so ernst und
deswegen lassen sie sich auch daran
erinnern wenn sie sagen wir Grüne tragen
diesen Staat diese Gesellschaft und
diese Demokratie dann lassen sie sich
sagen ihre offene Kompromiss Unfähigkeit
ihre ideologische Verweigerungshaltung
ihr Ignorieren der Ängste und Nöte der
Menschen das trägt diese Gesellschaft
nicht sondern es ignoriert diese
Gesellschaft das ist die Wahrheit an
dieser Stelle
der Bundeskanzler die Menschen sind
schwer verunsichert viele haben schlicht
Angst diese Woche hat die R+V Studie zu
den Ängsten in Deutschland neue Zahlen
veröffentlicht Geld sorgen dominieren
die Ängste der deutschen 67 Prozent
haben Angst sich ihr Leben nicht mehr
leisten zu können sie haben Herr
Bundeskanzler einen doppelbums
angekündigt steht geblieben ist davon
nur doppelte Fragezeichen Ausgestaltung
der gaspreisbremse unklar Ausgestaltung
der strompreisbremse unklar Sicherheit
der Netzstabilität unklar diese Politik
schafft kein Vertrauen sie schafft neue
Ängste meine Damen und Herren
die Kommission hat die Vorschläge
gemacht sie haben bisher nicht darauf
reagiert sie sagen nicht wie sie
Haushalte wie sie Wirtschaft wie sie
Mittelstand entlasten wollen aber sie
fordern von uns ein dass sie Zustimmung
bekommen für 200 Milliarden neue
Schulden diese hier morgen zur
Abstimmung stellen sehr geehrter Herr
Bundeskanzler lassen Sie sich dies an
dieser Stelle auch sagen diesen Blanco
Wumms werden Sie von uns schlichtweg
nicht bekommen
und was sie diese Woche abgeliefert
haben in ihrer Koalition das hat die
Ängste übrigens nicht kleiner werden
lassen ihr Machtwort zu notwendig das
offensichtlich auch war ist ein Zeichen
der Ohnmacht diese Koalition und wenn
Sie schon Herr Bundeskanzler ihr
schärfstes Schwert die
Richtlinienkompetenz des Kanzlers wenn
sie es schon nutzen warum denn dann
nicht konsequent sondern nur
halbherzig kein einziges Problem dass
sie offensichtlich anders als ihr
Wirtschaftsminister für Januar Februar
und März identifiziert haben ist im
April des nächsten Jahres gelöst
deswegen ist ihre Entscheidung falsch an
dieser Stelle die Kernkraft nicht
weiterlaufen zu lassen
der Bundeskanzler sie haben hier vorhin
an diesem Rednerpult gesagt die
Energiepreise sind eine große
Bewährungsprobe ja vor allem für die
mittleren und kleinen für die normalen
Einkommen für den Mittelstand sie haben
hier vorhin an diesem Rednerpult gesagt
die Energiepreise müssen runter warum
verweigern sie den Menschen dann die
preisentlastung durch das Weiterlaufen
der Kernkraftwerke des Ifo-Institut hat
deutlich gemacht weiterlaufen der
Kernkraftwerke ist ein wesentlicher
Beitrag zur Reduzierung der
Energiepreise in Deutschland kommen sie
ihren eigenen Anspruch nachher
Bundeskanzler
ich habe übrigens vermisst Herr
Bundeskanzler dass sie
hier ihr ständiges versprechen
wiederholt haben dass wir inzwischen von
ihnen gewohnt sind you never walk alone
dieses ständige versprechen was die FDP
jetzt auch schon für sie wiederholt hat
noch mal eine ganze besonders
interessante Wendung in dieser Woche
bekommen wenn man sich das Verhalten
innerhalb der Ampelkoalition innerhalb
ihrer Bundesregierung angeschaut hat
wissen Sie Herr Bundeskanzler wie der
Blick der Öffentlichkeit der Bevölkerung
auf diese Ampel auf diese Regierung
inzwischen ist hier sitzt der
Bundeskanzler you never walk alone und
neben ihm sitzt üblicherweise der
Vizekanzler Deadman Walking das ist der
Blick der Bevölkerung auf diese
Bundesregierung
wenn es ein Machtwort braucht Herr
Bundeskanzler dann überlegen Sie sich
bitte ob Sie nicht dieses Machtwort
wirklich sinnvoll nutzen wollen es wäre
notwendig in dieser Lage jetzt die
Bestellung der Brennstäbe vorzunehmen
den weiterlauf der Kernkraft zu
ermöglichen Versorgungssicherheit zu
schaffen und Preise zu senken das wäre
ein Auftrag den Sie mitnehmen können
nach Europa nach Brüssel wenn sie
Machtworte sprechen dann sorgen Sie auch
für Ergebnisse die den Nöten der
Menschen helfen dankeschön
der musste eben sogar der Bundeskanzler
Schmunzeln
Alexander Dobrindt wieder voll in seinem
Element mit einer ziemlich harten
Abrechnung mit der Politik der
Bundesregierung und insbesondere mit den
Bündnisgrünen nächste Rednerin hier in
der Aussprache zum Europäischen Rat
heute und morgen nach der
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
Chantal Kopf für die bündnisgröße
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen seit einigen Tagen liefert
Frankreich Gas nach Deutschland dass wir
nach unserer selbstverschuldeten
Abhängigkeit von Russland benötigen und
Deutschland wiederum hilft Frankreich
bei der Stromversorgung das ist gelebte
europäische Solidarität
nun kommt es aber darauf am gesamt
europäisch die Energiepolitik und die
gaseinkäufe deutlich besser zu
koordinieren damit Putin die EU-Staaten
nicht noch einfacher gegeneinander
ausspielen kann und übrigens auch nicht
Länder in anderen Welt teilen gegen
Europa
wenn wir von überlappenden Krisen
sprechen dann müssen wir noch viel
ernsthafter über das Klima sprechen die
EU macht sich mit dem Green Deal und mit
Fit for fifty five auf den Weg zur
Klimaneutralität und auch wenn wir noch
nie ambitioniertere Pläne hatten um
unsere Lebensgrundlagen zu sichern sind
wir noch weit vom Ziel entfernt und
jetzt hat Putins Wirtschaftskrieg den
Kontinent und eine Energiekrise gestürzt
die existenzielle sorgen auslöst Hilfe
Entlastung Solidarität sind das Gebot
der Stunde aber
wenn Rufe laut werden jetzt mal langsam
zu machen mit Sorgfaltspflichten mit
Klimaschutz mit dem Green Deal dann ist
das genau die falsche Antwort der Green
Deal gilt wir können nicht warten bis
alle anderen Krisen irgendwie irgendwann
verschwunden sind die Klimakrise wartet
darauf nicht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und was hat uns denn in diese Situation
in dieser Abhängigkeit von Autokratien
gebracht unser blindes Vertrauen in
fossile Energie deswegen müssen wir uns
endlich befreien von fossilen
Brennstoffen deswegen brauchen wir einen
Energieeffizienzgesetz deswegen brauchen
wir den vorgezogenen Kohleausstieg und
deswegen setzt die Ampel alle Hebel im
Bewegung um den Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
zu beschleunigen
für die Energiewende benötigen wir aber
auch die europäische Ebene den Ausbau
und den Schutz einer gemeinsamen
Energieinfrastruktur in der EU und in
der europäischen politischen
Gemeinschaft gemeinsame Projekte bei
Solar bei Wind und bei grünem
Wasserstoff
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn wir
uns an die Fluten im Aartal erinnern an
den zurückliegenden Hitze Sommer und vor
allem wenn wir an die 1700 Hochwasser
Toten im Pakistan denken dann wird klar
wir brauchen nicht weniger Tempo beim
Klimaschutz sondern wesentlich mehr
Paris gilt ich bin unsere
Außenministerin Anna-Lena baerbock
dankbar dass sie eine group of friends
für eine ambitionierte EU-Klimapolitik
auf den Weg gebracht hat die EU muss die
Pariser Klimaziele beim Wort nehmen und
sie muss sich noch stärker ihrer
Verantwortung gegenüber den Ländern
bewusst werden die am stärksten von der
Klimakrise betroffen sind obwohl sie am
wenigsten dazu beigetragen haben
wir leben in Zeiten in denen Menschen
aufgrund von Dürren und Fluten ihre
Heimat verlieren und in denen
Ungerechtigkeit zwischen globalen Norden
und globalen Süden auch zunehmend zum
geostrategischen Risiko wird liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
was wir jetzt brauchen das ist
Kooperation auf Augenhöhe das sind faire
Energie
transformations- und
handelspartnerschaften die sowohl der EU
aber eben auch unseren Partnern den Weg
in eine lebenswerte zukunftsebenen und
das ist auch unsere Antwort auf Putins
Imperialismus und auf die Einflussnahme
eines autoritären Chinas in Asien Afrika
und auf dem gesamten Globus und apropos
China lassen Sie uns bitte nicht unsere
Fehler wiederholen wir dürfen uns nicht
erpressbar machen es ist nicht klug
wichtige Infrastruktur in die Hände
Chinas zu geben lassen sie uns endlich
eine vorausschauende Politik machen eine
vorausschauende Politik dafür stehen
Bündnis 90 die Grünen vielen Dank
Chantal Kopf war das für die Bündnis
Grünen und der nächste Redner hier in
der eigentlich europapolitischen Debatte
ist ein wahrer Europäer lange dort
gewesen europäisch Parlament viel zu
Präsident gewesen und jetzt der zweite
Saturn im Bundestag Alexander
flamsters in der Ukraine nimmt auf
unseren Kontinent unterschiedlich
Erscheinungsformen an wir wissen dass
Russland gegen uns ein energiekrieg
führt in der großen Analyse der vier
deutschen Übertragungsnetzbetreiber
heißt es die Situation im Deutschen
stromnetzwert im kommenden Winter
äußerst angespannt all die hat gestern
angekündigt aus energiekostengründen
seine Öffnungszeiten zu verkürzen
Ingenieure von stromnetzbetreibern sind
derzeit dabei zu prüfen Kunden in
Süddeutschland zeitweise vom Netz zu
nehmen weil es dort nicht gelingt die
Versorgung mit Strom aus den Windparks
im Norden sicherzustellen und das will
ich hier deutlich sagen meine Damen und
Herren bei aller Offenheit für Debatten
die der Bundeskanzler hier eben
angesprochen hat einen Beitrag und das
sind Tipps der CSU für die
Energieversorgung in unserem Land gerade
der Freistaat Bayern ist der Problembär
unter den Bundesländern wenn es darum
geht die Energieversorgung zu sichern
die gute Nachricht meine Damen und
Herren in diesem Zusammenhang ist dass
die drei Kernkraftwerke die noch laufen
jetzt am Netz bleiben das hat der
Bundeskanzler in dieser Woche verkündet
und diese Nachricht meine Damen und
Herren die freut auch unsere
europäischen Partner denn wir sind in
der Europäischen Union nicht nur aus
politischen Gründen zu unserem Glück
vereint wir sind auch durch Pipelines
und Kabel und interconnectoren
miteinander verbunden und vernetzt wir
haben profitiert von den flüssiggast
Terminals und dem pipeline-kapazitäten
in Holland und Belgien und Skandinavien
die haben dafür gesorgt dass unsere
Gasspeicher gefüllt werden konnten wir
helfen den Franzosen wenn bei denen die
Kernkraftwerke teilweise ausfallen mit
Strom Lieferungen aus Deutschland jetzt
kriegen wir Gas aus Frankreich meine
Damen und Herren wenn bei uns ein Netz
eng auftritt wenn bei uns Strommangel
auftritt dann hat das unmittelbare
Folgen für unsere Nachbarn in der
Europäischen Union deswegen muss der
Weiterbetrieb der deutschen
Kernkraftwerke auch als eine symbolische
Geste gesehen werden er verhindert
nämlich die Erzählung von einem
Deutschland was einerseits die Hilfe
seiner Partner in Anspruch nimmt aber
andererseits nicht dazu bereit ist seine
eigenen Befindlichkeiten bei der eigenen
Energieversorgung zurückzustellen
Deutschland muss seine
energieerzeugungskapazitäten jetzt
ausschöpfen im Interesse aller
europäischen Nachbarn und der ganzen
Europäischen Union bleiben wir also
meine Damen und Herren zu unserem Glück
vereint ich hoffe das ist das Signal das
von diesem Europäischen Rat ausgeht
herzlichen Dank
ja diese Hoffnung teilen viele bleibt
abzuwarten ob es da wirklich zu
Ergebnissen kommt heute und morgen bei
einer gemeinsamen Energiepolitik der
Europäer Matthias Miersch jetzt für die
SPD liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
Kollege Dobrindt
ich habe eben mitgeschrieben und ich
hoffe dass ich sie richtig wiedergebe
und es aber inhaltlich einen
Missverständnis gewesen ist sie haben
gesagt auf die Frage der Kollegin
Hasselmann
wir sollten hier Ängste und Nöte der
Menschen nicht ignorieren Herr Kollege
Dobrindt diese Vorwürfe finde ich
sollten wir gerade in dieser Zeit nicht
unter Demokraten machen wir nehmen hier
alle die Ängste und Nöte von weiten
Teilen der Bevölkerung ernst aber unsere
Antworten unsere Vorschläge sind
vielleicht unterschiedlich das sollte
unser Konsens sein hier in diesem Haus
und wenn sie dem Bundeskanzler Herr
Dobrindt und Herr Merz vorwerfen man
kann es nicht und man handelt nicht dann
finde ich müssen Sie sich einfach auch
immer wieder gefallen lassen dass wir
uns mit ihren Vorschlägen denn so wie
sie überhaupt da sind dann
auseinandersetzen der Kollege dürr hat
einen ihrer Vorschläge ja schon mal
gemacht drei will ich Ihnen hier sagen
und ich kann Ihnen nur sagen ich bin
heilfroh dass in diesen Zeiten nicht sie
regieren sondern die Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz und kein anderer der ruhig hier
diese Bundesregierung führt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn was sie als erstes ganz groß
verkündet haben nach wenigen Wochen des
Kriegsausbruchs war dass sie
vorgeschlagen haben und da kann man sie
nie aus der Verantwortung lassen dass
die dass die Bundesregierung ein
einseitiges Gas embargo gegenüber
Russland verkünden sollte das wäre fatal
für alle in Deutschland gewesen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und jetzt kommen Sie mit dem nächsten
und sagen es gibt eine große Lösung die
alles
das sind die Laufzeitverlängerung und da
muss man Ihnen noch sagen da twittert
sogar noch der zuständige
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
Jens Spahn dass diese Technologie
putinfrei und verlässlich sei wissen Sie
eigentlich welche Abhängigkeiten
zwischen russischen Brennstäben und
osteuropäischen Atomkraftwerken bestehen
wer hier von Putin freispreicht der hat
das ganze Thema nicht verstanden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wer von Verlässlichkeit redet und
sich anguckt was gerade in Frankreich
passiert wo die Hälfte der
Atomkraftwerke nicht am Netz ist der
sagt hier den Menschen etwas Falsches
ich hätte mir gewünscht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das so wie der
Bundeskanzler von seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz gebraucht macht das
Frau Merkel manches Mal im
Auseinandersetzung mit ihnen bei den
erneuerbaren Energien gemacht hätte dann
wären wir weitaus weiter gewesen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ganz fatal darüber und jetzt müssen
sie es noch mal auch ganz kurz angucken
jetzt haben sie hier geredet eben und
haben gesagt man müsste in irgendeiner
Form Bremsen einführen
energiepreisbremsen und sie haben
scheinbar den Bundeskanzler nicht
zugehört denn er hat sich heute
ausdrücklich zu den
kommissionsergebnissen bekannt und hat
gesagt diese Bundesregierung arbeitet
gerade an der Umsetzung und das ist ein
Riesenschritt dass wir hier jetzt
Sicherheit geben Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
und Unternehmen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
aber was machen sie was machen sie in
dieser Phase sie werden morgen den 200
Milliarden die notwendig sind um diese
Sicherheit zu geben nicht zustimmen weil
sie keinen Blankoscheck angeblich geben
wollen woher sollen denn bitte die
Gelder kommen die im Dezember die
Haushalte stützen sollen das macht
keinen Sinn sie Irrlichtern in dieser
Krise und Sie können es schlichtweg
nicht stellen sie sich nicht hier hin
und sagen sie können und Sie können es
nicht sondern sie müssen wirklich
belastbare Vorschläge hier vorlegen alle
drei Punkte wären dieser strös gewesen
in dieser in dieser Krise gut dass sie
nicht regieren vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
es ist immer noch die Aussprache zum
Europäischen Rat hier im Deutschen
Bundestag nach der Regierungserklärung
des Bundeskanzlers heute morgen hat
jetzt als nächster Redner guter
Kriechbaum von der cdu/csu der
europapolitische Sprecher das Wort frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
Herr Bundeskanzler wir haben heute
Morgen sehr entschlossene Worte von ihm
gehört zum Thema Ukraine und dem
Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine das begrüßen wir ausdrücklich
wir hätten uns aber diese Rede und
diesen Inhalt schon vor einem halben
Jahr gewünscht diese Entschlossenheit
haben sie immer vermissen lassen und
Fakt ist eben auch dass durch die
Zögerlichkeit durch das Zaudern
insbesondere beim Thema der
Waffenlieferungen viele Menschenleben
hätten gerettet werden können wenn auch
wir in Deutschland früher gehandelt
hätten das ist allerdings nicht der Fall
sie haben auch über Europa geredet die
Frage die sich mir stellt welches Europa
meinen sie eigentlich ist es ein Europa
der Gemeinsamkeiten oder ist das ein
Europa der Alleingänge sie haben nichts
gesagt zu Frankreich sie haben nichts
gesagt zu China sie haben nichts gesagt
zu den USA gestern wurden die
deutsch-französischen
Regierungskonsultationen abgesagt mit
der Begründung dass vier Minister ihres
Kabinetts
paralleltermine hätten keine Zeit hätten
ist Ihnen in diesem Augenblick
eigentlich bewusst dass wo wir doch alle
wissen dass diese Begründung ohnehin
vorgeschoben ist welche unglaubliche
Affront das Gegenüber Frankreich ist zu
sagen die haben besseres zu tun als an
den deutsch-französischen
Regierungskonsultationen teilzunehmen
das ist ein Schaden dem Sie hier dem
Verhältnis von Deutschland und
Frankreich zufügen wir hätten genügend
Themen zu besprechen mit unseren
französischen Freunden wie geht es
weiter bei FKS sie hatten auf ihre
Prager redebezug genommen da hatten sie
auch vom Raketen Abwehrschild gesprochen
mit Frankreich 0,0 kommuniziert
überhaupt kam das deutsch-französische
Verhältnis in der Prager Rede überhaupt
gar nicht vor dass sich Frankreich dann
darin nicht wiederfindet darf wohl kaum
Erstaunen wir hätten uns gewünscht dass
sie heute Abend heute morgen noch etwas
gesagt hätten beispielsweise zum Thema
der europäischen politischen
Gemeinschaft welche Perspektive wird den
Beitrittskandidaten geboten das ist ein
Vorschlag der ebenfalls von macron kam
kein Wort dazu China gehen wir weiter
China sie werden China bereisen Anfang
November auch wiederum ein Alleingang
nicht mit den europäischen Freunden und
Partnern kommuniziert es wäre die
Gelegenheit gewesen ähnlich wie es
macron im übrigen auch einmal gemacht
hatte dass er Bundeskanzlerin Merkel
Jean-Claude Juncker und eben auch den
chinesischen Präsidenten an einen Tisch
geholt hatte dann über die Dinge zu
sprechen die uns in Europa gemeinsam
bewegen wenn wir wissen dass zwei
Drittel aller Halbleiter weltweit aus
Taiwan kommen wenn wir wissen dass eine
hundertprozentige
Möglichkeit gegenüber China bei der
Frage der Antibiotika besteht dann wäre
es schon einmal sinnvoll diese Dinge
europäisch anzugehen und nicht in einem
nationalen Alleingang wir haben
[Applaus]
wir haben einen weiteren eyeline
alleiner das ist dieser hummi Rums mit
200 Milliarden Euro
0,0 mit den europäischen Partnern
kommuniziert abermals Sendepause es wäre
gut gewesen auch hier im Vorfeld wie das
im übrigen auch früher der Fall war mit
Frankreich und mit den anderen
europäischen Freunden zu sprechen
richtig ist dass wir hier die deutsche
Wirtschaft unterstützen falsch ist es
das alleine zu machen und ohne jede
Kommunikation mit unseren Freunden
ebenfalls ein Alleingang und ohne die
Kommunikation Thema Energie es ist gut
dass jetzt die Laufzeit der Kraftwerke
der Kernkraftwerke verlängert wird aber
wir dürfen uns doch hier nicht in die
eigene Tasche lügen es ist ein
streckbetrieb bis April es wäre besser
gewesen dem Vorschlag auch der FDP hier
zu folgen und die Laufzeit der AKWs
generell zu verlängern das wäre jetzt
erforderlich gewesen zumal Europa wir
auch an der Stelle kritisch beäugt
werden es heißt nämlich ihr deutschen
wenn ihr jetzt die Angebotsseite
verknappt dann verteuert sich eben nicht
nur die Energie für euch sondern eben
auch für uns den Strom ist ein gut was
international gehandelt wird und Angebot
und Nachfrage Regeln nun einmal den
Preis aber
auf Finanzminister Lindner ich muss
Ihnen schon auch sagen
ist persönlich war jedenfalls erstaunt
dass als es um die 200 Milliarden ging
sie als Finanzminister da ein anderes
Preisschild nicht dahinter gehängt war
sie hätten nämlich locker sagen können
wie ich mache es als Finanzminister zur
Bedingung dass die Laufzeiten der AKWs
entsprechend verlängert werden und dann
erteile ich auch als Finanzminister
meine Zustimmung das war ein schwerer
strategischer Fehler den Sie innerhalb
der Verhandlungen hier gemacht haben und
das müssen sie sich eben auch ankreiden
lassen wir haben kein Fortgang beim
Thema ceta Wie geht es hier voran auch
das wäre heute morgen eine perfekte
Gelegenheit gewesen hier einmal etwas zu
sagen Klarheit zu schaffen zum x-mal
hier im Deutschen Bundestag verschoben
das ist ein Affront gegenüber Kanada
stattdessen möchte ihr
Wirtschaftsminister hier
die Verhandlungen mit Chile wieder auf
die Handelsbeziehung mit hier das
Handelsabkommen mit Chile wieder
aufmachen vielleicht sollte man mal auch
daran denken dass die Handelspolitik
eine Kompetenz ist die zu 100 Prozent
bei der Europäischen Union liegt und
nicht beim Wirtschaftsminister der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland deswegen war
diese Regierungserklärung eine Rede der
verpassten Chancen und generell sollte
vielleicht das afrikanische Sprichwort
beherzigt werden wenn du schnell gehen
willst dann gehe alleine aber wenn du
weit gehen willst dann geh gemeinsam und
wir brauchen mehr Gemeinsamkeit in
diesen kritischen Tagen
und der Kriechbaum ist europapolitischer
Sprecher der CDU CSU endet hier mit
einem afrikanischen Sprichwort seiner
Rede Rednerin ist Ariane
sie ist im Ausschuss für Angelegenheiten
der Europäischen Union für die SPD redet
sie sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
wertekrise seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
zeitenwände zeitenwände mit vielen
Dimensionen deswegen möchte ich jetzt
den Blick einmal etwas weiter wenden in
die Langfristperspektive eine enorme
Solidarität und Entschlossenheit ist
eine EU sichtbar geworden darin zeigt
sich eine erneuertes Europa eine
belastbare Gemeinschaft jenseits der
Konfliktfelder erstagter Nationalismen
eingeschränkter Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
Pressefreiheit
Krisen sind die Stunde der Exekutive
Achim postwies zu Recht auf die
Notwendigkeit der Vertiefung und
Erweiterung der EU hin eine erweiterte
Europäische Union wird langfristig
gelingen wenn ein Europa der Regierungen
als ein Europa der Menschen und
gefüttert werden kann so fordern ist die
Ergebnisse der Zukunftskonferenz und so
fordert es der bürgerblick auf die EU
einer der Gründerväter der europäischen
Einigung der französische Beamte
jean-monnaie ließ uns den Satz zurück
Europa wird in Krisen geschmiedet und
ist am Ende die Summe der Lösungen die
für diese Krisen gewählt wird diese
Krise hat die Macht uns entweder zu
enzweien oder sie wird uns befähigen
jene Probleme zu lösen die aus
mangelnder Zusammenarbeit und
Uneinigkeit entstanden sind hier kann
insofern eine wirkliche europäische
Chance erwachsen
in der Debatte in Deutschland ist die
europäische gender- und
Gleichstellungspolitik ein
unterschätzter Aspekt
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit und
gleichberechtigte Teilhabe aller
Menschen sind kein Selbstzweck sondern
Voraussetzung für nachhaltigen Frieden
Sicherheit und Wohlstand der Europäische
Rat wird mit sich heute und morgen den
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit
stets lag die Stärke der Gemeinschaft in
ihrer Fähigkeit tragfähige Brücken nach
außen zu schlagen wie aktuell mit der
europäischen politischen Gemeinschaft
eine wachsende EU wird jedoch neben
einer gemeinsamen Wirtschafts- und so
und Sicherheitspolitik nur als ein
Europa der Mehrheitsentscheidung
gestärkt da innerer Demokratie und mehr
gemeinsamer Steuer- und Fiskalpolitik
stark bleiben können
das Europa der gleichen
Lebensverhältnisse und einer
europäischen Identität gelingt wenn der
Tiefe der Zusammenarbeit von Regierungen
über die Parlamente in die
Bürgerschaften reicht dafür sind
allerdings lose Zusammenschlüsse zu
wenig
die EU ist wichtige Schritte für ein
modernes gerechtes Europa der
bürger:innen gegangen da ist die
lohntransparenzrichtlinie die
arbeitnehmer:innen Einblick in die
Entlohnung gleichgestellter Kollegen
ermöglicht so lässt sich Lohngefälle
zwischen den Geschlechtern verringern
aber auch zwischen Menschen
unterschiedlicher Herkunft und
Berufsabschlüsse
EU-weit verdienen Frauen 14% weniger als
ihre männlichen Kollegen
europaweit sind aber auch vor allem
Frauen Verliererinnen der Krise sie sind
verstärkt auf der Flucht allein mit
Kindern und alten Angehörigen sie sind
stärker von der energie-armut
Gewalt und sexualisierte Gewalt an
Frauen und Kindern nimmt in Krisen nicht
nur zu sondern sie werden nach gerade
als Kriegswaffe eingesetzt
neben Energiesicherheit und Frieden wird
gelingender Klimaschutz wird immer mehr
wird gelingender Klimaschutz immer mehr
zur Grundlage für gleiche
Lebensverhältnisse nicht nur zwischen
den Geschlechtern sondern auch zwischen
den Ländern und Regionen der
klimasozialfonds ist ein gelungener
Ansatz der solidarischen Antwort auf die
sozialen Herausforderungen des
klimagerechten Umbaus der Wirtschaft
auch der europäische Mindestlohn ist mit
erstmals einheitlichen lohnstandards
eine zentrale Errungenschaft des
sozialen Europas atypische Beschäftigung
niedrigste Löhne prekäre Arbeit wie in
plattformökonomie und das Lohngefälle
zwischen Geschlechtern sind Themen die
wir national aber und vor allem auf der
EU-Ebene bekämpfen können und müssen
sozial und Steuerdumping darf kein
Wettbewerbsvorteil sein nirgendwo
deswegen sind diese Vorstöße wirkliche
Pionierarbeit im sozialen Europa
europäische erlebnis- und
Erwerbsbiografie unterstützt durch
umfassende jugendbildungsprogramme
werden in der Zeit eine europäische
Identität prägen die künftigen
erasmus+-generationen werden aus einer
teilhabegerechten europasicht den
Phantomschmerz untergegangener reiche
und verlorener Großmächte ebenso wenig
spüren wie sie nationengrenzen fühlen
das Recht jeder Europäer in
das Recht jeder Europäer in auf
Sicherheit Gleichstellung und
Chancengerechtigkeit an jedem Ort an dem
sie ihr Leben gestalten möchten muss
daher der Anspruch auf die
Lebenswirklichkeit der EU für morgen
sein sie fordert Integrität Solidarität
Augenhöhe von allen Staaten nicht
weniger als das bedeutet am Ende eine
gelungene Zeitenwende für Europa vielen
Dank
also Hofreiter hat das Wort für Bündnis
90 die Grünen
Anton Hofreiter von der Bündnisgrünen
ist Vorsitzender des
Ausschusses für Angelegenheiten der
Europäischen Union so heißt es korrekt
und hat jetzt das Wort liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die großen
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit die
Klimakrise wie die jetzige Energiekrise
oder den verbrecherischen Angriffskrieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine werden wir
nur bewältigen wenn wir verstärkt
europäisch zusammenarbeiten Deutschland
ist ein großes Deutschland ist ein
mächtiges Land ein Vergleich zu diesen
Herausforderungen ist es auch ein
kleines Land und wir müssen die Ukraine
noch mehr stärker unterstützen und wir
müssen auch dafür sorgen dass die
Ukraine noch mal mehr Waffen zur
Verteidigung bekommt und wenn ich mir
hier anhöre was von dieser Seite und
dieser Seite erzählt wird nämlich dass
man die Waffenlieferungen einstellen
soll und doch einfach mal verhandeln
soll dann ist es naiv und verantwortlich
und einfach schlichtweg unterlassene
Hilfeleistung
sie fordern sozusagen
auch zu ver
Handlungen ich gemerkt dass Russland die
Ukraine angegriffen hat und das Russland
nicht bereit ist zu verhandeln und da
hilft es nichts die Opfer aufzufordern
zu verhandeln sondern hilft es die Opfer
zu unterstützen dass sie sich wehren
können nur dann haben wir eine Chance zu
echten Verhandlungen zu kommen nur dann
haben wir eine Chance zufrieden zu
kommen
[Applaus]
eine Zwischenfrage zulassen es scheint
mir so
Jan Karte der Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer der Linksfraktion frau
Präsidentin vielen Dank Kollege
Hofreiter als ich will auf die Polemik
jetzt gar nicht weiter eingehen aber ich
hätte schon noch mal eine konkrete
Nachfrage wenn sie sagen dass also die
Forderung nach Verhandlungen also per se
unmoralisch oder sonst irgendwas ist
also das ist schon relativ absurder
Ansatz vor allem wenn er vom linken
Flügel der Grünen hier vorgetragen wird
ist aber eine andere Frage was mich
wirklich noch mal interessieren würde
wenn wir sowohl mal zurückgehen nehmen
wir mal den großen Bundeskanzler Willy
Brandt der hat ja damals also
beispielsweise mit Leonie Breschnew
verhandelt der jetzt ja nun kein
basisdemokrat gewesen ist fanden sie
deswegen diese Art von Politik
eigentlich falsch und was sagen sie
eigentlich zu den Verhandlungen die
beispielsweise
uterisch geführt hat auch mit dem
putinregime als es um die Ausfuhr von
Weizen ging halten sie das jetzt auch
per se für unmoralisch das würde mich
interessieren wie da ihre Stellung zu
ist
vielen Dank für diese äußerst
ungeschickte Frage wenn ich sie haben
bewusst versucht die Wahrheit zu
verdrehen nämlich was ich ihnen vorwerfe
ist dass sie die Ukraine nicht weiter
unterstützen wollen und nicht weiter mit
Waffen unterstützen wollen nämlich das
haben Sie gesagt Sie wollen keine
weiteren Waffen an die Ukraine liefern
das ist nichts anderes als wir
unterlassene Hilfeleistung dann gibt es
nämlich gar keine Verhandlungen mehr
weiß nämlich dann gar keine Ukraine mehr
gibt es gäbe keine Ukraine mehr wenn wir
unintelligible unverantwortliche Politik
die sich interessanterweise mit denen
denken umsetzen würden und das ist das
Problem das ist das Problem des
unanständige an ihren Forderungen
und jetzt und jetzt sozusagen zur Union
es ist ja allgemein bekannt dass ich der
Meinung bin und die Bundesregierung
dränge noch mehr zu tun und ich höre das
auch immer wieder aus der Union dass die
Bundesregierung mehr tun sollte aber
wenn wir mitten in der Debatte sind ob
die Bundesregierung noch mehr tun sollte
und ich bin froh was wir bereits
geliefert haben dann meldet sich die
Union und Herr Merz persönlich zu Wort
und wirft den Ukrainern sozialtourismus
vor das ist ein russisches
propagandamarativ und damit
konterkarieren sie Bemühungen die
Ukraine noch stärker zu unterstützen und
dann sind sie nicht mehr in der Lage
sich ernsthaft zu entschuldigen sondern
nur halbgar das macht die ganzen
Bemühungen die dringend notwendig sind
einfach unglaubwürdig jede Kritik ist
russische Propaganda ja einfach und es
ist so ab und man muss halt
ehrlicherweise sagen ja wir tun vieles
auf europäischer Ebene aber wir müssen
einfach auch noch stärker werden wir
haben zu lang gezögert das müssen wir
uns ehrlich anrechnen dass wir auf
europäischer Ebene für ein gemeinsamen
erdgaseinkauf kämpfen da waren wir zu
langsam das ist gut dass wir das jetzt
tun aber wir müssen nur schneller werden
und wir müssen auch klarer werden mehr
auf der einen Seite dürfen wir nicht
drauf reinfallen wenn uns gesagt wird
die 200 Milliarden bei uns sind
uneuropäisch wenn andere Länder das
gleiche machen aber es fällt halt leicht
wenn wir so kommunizieren wie wir es zum
Teil getan haben deshalb ich glaube in
allen Fällen tut es uns allen gut wenn
wir als Bundesregierung als
Regierungsfraktionen im Idealfall als
Gesamtes als alle Demokraten im
Parlament noch stärker darauf achten was
sind die Interessen was sind die
Bedürfnisse unserer Nachbarn und dafür
sagen dass wir europäisch gemeinsam
zusammenhalten
vielen Dank
Markus tun sie das Wort für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wenn ich so die
Kritik der Opposition an der
Regierungserklärung des Kanzlers heute
höre da muss ich feststellen
substanziell war das jetzt nicht von
ihnen nicht Herr Merz etc sondern da war
eigentlich gar keine Kritik das heißt so
schlecht kann das heute morgen gar nicht
gewesen sein sondern der Bundeskanzler
hat sehr deutlich gesagt was sie Haltung
der Bundesregierung was die Haltung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland ist und mit
welcher Haltung er in diesen
Europäischen Rat geht und dass er das
zentrale Ziel hat dort zu einer Einigung
zu kommen mit unseren europäischen
Freundinnen und Freunden und das ist gut
für unser Land und das ist gut für
Europa
eines ist klar liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Energiekrise diese Energiekrise
diese Energie Preiskrise kann nur
europäisch gelöst werden und das ist
deutlich geworden heute morgen es geht
um einen gemeinsamen Einkauf es geht um
Preisgrenzen für den Gasmarkt auch das
muss europäisch gelöst werden es geht
uns um die Solidarität der
Mitgliedstaaten und es geht zentral auch
darum gemeinsam Energie zu sparen darum
geht es in diesen Fragen
und deshalb sind erste Schritte gemacht
worden es ist heute morgen auch schon
erwähnt worden es wird ein gemeinsam
Gaseinkauf geben auf europäischer Ebene
und es gibt Gaslieferungen aus
Frankreich und es gibt unsere
europäische Verantwortung auch zu
unseren europäischen Partnern auch sie
mit Gasen unterstützen beispielsweise
Tschechien die Gas brauchen die aber
auch Strom liefern also das ist alles zu
begrüßen und ich bin der tiefen
Überzeugung dass das auf dem
Europäischen Rat gelingen wird denn
eines ist klar Europa war immer dann
stark wenn es in der Krise sich zusammen
nehmen musste wenn es in der Krise
verstanden hat alle gemeinsam schaffen
wir das nur als Einheit und ich glaube
das ist deutlich dass man vorher bevor
man in den Rat geht auch
unterschiedliche Positionen hat das ist
durchaus richtig und das muss man auch
immer zugrunde liegen und diese
europäischen Lösungen die wir in den
nächsten zwei Tagen erwarten und auch
erhoffen und ihn davon auch überzeugt
sind die sind der Grundstein für G7
Vereinbarungen die in der
g7-präsidentschaft der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und auch mit unserem
Bundeskanzler dann ein auf eine breitere
Basis gesetzt werden das ist der Punkt
wo wir sagen Europa gemeinsam und dann
G7 dann wird das auch funktionieren was
mir dabei
was wir dabei aber nicht vergessen
dürfen ist und ich finde das ist heute
noch ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen in
den Debatten hier ist die Frage wie wir
mit dem globalen Süden umgehen wir
dürfen das nicht vergessen es geht um
Ernährungssicherheit es geht um
Energiesicherheit auch für die
Ärmsten und armen Länder in dieser Welt
europa muss sich für diesen
Süden in engagieren sonst sind sie in
den dispoten sonst sind wir sie den
dispoten dieser Welt ausgeliefert denn
geht es darum dass China oder Russland
deren Politik bestimmen und das kann
nicht im Interesse Deutschlands nicht im
Interesse Europa sein und nicht im
Interesse der Demokratien in dieser Welt
das muss man glaube ich auch noch mal
herausstellen und dann will ich das auch
an der Stelle sagen ich bin da ganz ganz
zuversichtlich und auch froh dass wir
einen Kanzler an der Spitze haben der
ein europäischer Kanzler ist wir sind in
einer Krise und zum ersten Mal bin ich
sehr beruhigt dass ein Kanzler zu einem
europäischen Rad fährt in einer Krise
der nicht die Absicht hat das
auszusitzen wie wir das 16 Jahre unter
Angela Merkel hier erlebt haben das ist
ein starker Kanzler und das gehört sich
auch so
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland und der
Kanzler wird sich für europäische und
Lösungen einsetzen und da geht es um
wichtige Punkte die wir erarbeiten
müssen eines ist zum Beispiel auch die
Resilienz in der Energieversorgung und
den Lieferketten können wir eine
europäisch erreichen darum geht es auch
auf diesen Gipfel wir brauchen keine
nationalen alleinergänge sondern wir
brauchen
Solidarität international das heißt
europäisch und auch auf der G7 Ebene und
ich will ein Ende meiner Rede ein
Gründervater
der Europäischen Union zitieren der
vielleicht noch mal deutlich macht worum
worauf es ankommt worum es uns geht
Spark
hat Mal zitiert oder hat mal gesagt und
ich finde der Satz ist immer noch
richtig in Europa gibt es zwei Typen von
Staaten kleine Staaten und Staaten die
noch nicht verstanden haben dass sie
klein sind und das bedeutet für uns
gemeinsam Solidarität auf europäischer
Ebene und dafür kämpfen wir mit dieser
Bundesregierung in dieser Koalition und
mit diesem Bundeskanzler vielen Dank
Markus Töns war das für die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion der vorletzte
Redner in der Aussprache zum
Europäischen Rat ist Robert farle
Fraktionslose Abgeordneter war mal in
der AFD
[Musik]
sie können an mir
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren sehr geehrter
Herr Bundeskanzler Scholz
meiner Meinung nach befindet sich unser
Land in größter Gefahr
und ich glaube dass sie diese Gefahr in
ihrer ganzen Dimension
noch nicht realisiert haben
weil sie viel zu sehr einem Diktator in
der Ukraine Vertrauen der als
präsidentendarsteller des olligarchen
kolomäuskie an die Macht gekommen ist
und im Auftrag der USA in Russland einen
Regimewechsel herbeiführen soll
dieser lensky hat vor wenigen Tagen
aufgerufen einen präventiven Atomschlag
gegen Russland durchzuführen
und schließt per Dekret sämtliche
Verhandlungen mit Putin über einen
Waffenstillstand aus
es ist eben nicht gut in der
Verhandlungen ablehnt sondern es ist der
lensky der keinerlei Verhandlungen
bereit ist und diese Sabotage durch
silensky für eine friedliche Lösung zu
finden die muss durchbrochen werden und
dazu fordere ich Sie als Bundeskanzler
auf alles in diesem Sinn zu unternehmen
und aus der Kriegsrhetorik dieses Landes
auszusteigen die überall in unseren
Massenmedien derzeit praktiziert wird
mit Rückendeckung von beiden versucht
ganz Westdeutschland in allen Krieg mit
Russland hineinzuführen und peilt einzig
und allein eine militärische Lösung des
Konflikts an das ist wortlautzelensky es
gibt nur eine militärische Lösung
eine solche militärische Lösung in einem
Konvention
Ellen atomacht überhaupt nicht geben
es sei denn man arbeitet final im Rahmen
einer
Eskalationsspirale Schritt für Schritt
auf den gesamten Weltuntergang hin
manche nennen das Armageddon oder sonst
wie aber ich kann Ihnen nur sagen aus
der Spirale muss man aus rauskommen in
dieser Situation ist von Ihnen Herr
Scholz Führungsstärke gefragt denn von
ihnen hängt ab dass endlich das
Wichtigste in Angriff genommen wird
nämlich endlich und sofort die
Herbeiführung eines Waffenstillstandes
einzuleiten und selensky zurückzupfeifen
der nicht über unser aller Schicksal
entscheiden kann und mit seinen
alleinggängen gestoppt werden muss
abgelaufen
ich hatte drei Minuten
gut wenn die rum sind das wichtigste
habe ich hier zum Ausdruck ge
bracht und mein letzter Satz in
[Musik]
diesem so sie haben die Möglichkeit
einzuwirken nutzen Sie Möglichkeit für
eine friedliche
Lösung
[Musik]
ja und das muss man auch klar sagen
nachdem ich vorhin es ja anders
interpretiert habe der Bundeskanzler ist
immer noch da er sitzt hier durch bis
zum letzten Redner der wird gleich
kommen nämlich Axel Schäfer Axel Schäfer
ist auch Sozialdemokrat und den wird er
sich jetzt noch anhören 15 Uhr beginnt
der Gipfel in Brüssel und der
Bundeskanzler hat die gesamte Debatte
hier quasi im Hohen Haus verbracht das
muss normal hervorgehoben werden bis zum
letzten renat Axel Schäfer jetzt mit dem
schönen roten Schaden frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen manchmal gibt
es besondere Zufälle was die redeabfolge
anbelangt
ich habe mich mit meinen Vorredner vor
fast 50 Jahren in Bochum darüber
gestritten
inwieweit wir die Intervention der
Sowjetunion und anderer Warschauer
pakt-staaten zur Niederschlagung des
Prager Frühlings verurteilen und dagegen
stehen einer der härtesten
Repräsentanten der DKP von MSP Spartacus
war Robert fahler der Verteidiger der
Verteidiger der Niederschlagung des
prager-frühlings Anfang der 70er Jahre
bei Bochumer Debatten ist heute
derjenige der versucht den ukrainischen
Präsidenten zu diffamieren und
niederzumachen das war eine Rede der
Schande die wir heute gehört haben
und es ist vielleicht auch ein
besonderes Stück oder Drama in der
deutschen Geschichte dass man von einem
Stalinisten zu einem Rechtsextremisten
mutieren kann ich bin froh dass es so
wenige davon in Deutschland noch gibt
und es ist gut so dass wir die
Diskussion so geführt haben heute wie
wir sie miteinander auf dieser Seite des
Hauses geführt haben
aber liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen lass uns
Angesicht der historischen Dimension ein
bisschen stärker auch Dinge einordnen
das was wir heute zu bewerkstelligen
haben ist tatsächlich die größte
Herausforderung seit 1945 und deshalb
müssen wir genau solche Maßstäbe anlegen
und selbst die deutsche
Wiedervereinigung war nur zum Teil
vergleichbar aber die Erfahrung von
damals waren und damals regierte FDP und
cdu/csu die SPD hatte die Mehrheit im
Bundesrat die Erfahrung damals war keine
der Parteien hatte eine Blaupause keine
hatte ein Konzept für die deutsche
Wiedervereinigung und trotzdem ist es
gemeinsam gelungen dieses zu einer
Erfolgsgeschichte zu machen wo wir ja
gemeinsam und zurechtstraf stolz sein
können
und ja es war möglich weil wir hier auf
Debatten geführt haben es war es war
damals auch möglich weil auch die
Opposition SPD insgesamt zugestimmt hat
und ich bin ganz sicher die Opposition
cdu/csu wird auch den Vorschlägen auch
was jetzt 200 Milliarden anbelangt
zustimmen ansonsten würden sie weder
ihrer deutschen noch ihre europäischen
Verantwortung bewusst
das sind wir beim liefern wir haben ja
wir haben ja das das große und das auch
historisch das große Glück bei einer
Zeitenwende
1969 Entspannungspolitik wurde einer
Bundeskanzler der schon als
Außenminister damit begonnen hat und als
es darum ging das Europäische
Währungssystem zu entwickeln bis hin zur
Direktwahl des Europäischen Parlaments
hatten wir einen Bundeskanzler der
vorher schon Finanzminister war und ich
finde es ist gut dass wir jetzt wieder
ein Bundeskanzler haben der schon als
Finanzminister in Europa gezeigt hat
Stichwort wieder Aufbau von Stichwort
globale Mindestbesteuerung dass er in
der Lage ist zu europäischen Lösungen zu
kommen die auch als praktisch umgesetzt
werden und das ist auch gut so
und liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen von der
Union weil wir bei Europa sind es wird
darauf ankommen dass wir weiterhin
kritisch was mehr sozial oder
konservativ oder liberale ökologisch und
so weiter ist kritisch diskutieren aber
eins dürfen wir nicht wir dürfen nicht
zulassen dass über die Regeln die wir
gemeinsam beschlossen haben dass die
infrage gestellt werden und die Regeln
die wir gemeinsam beschlossen haben
werden infrage gestellt eben nicht nur
durch Regierungen in Ungarn eine frühere
christdemokratische Partei die
ausgetreten ist oder in Polen sondern in
Zukunft auch in Schweden und Italien wo
Christdemokraten gestützt mit
Postfaschisten da hängt noch der
Mussolini beim Senatspräsidenten in der
Wohnung oder den antidemokratischen
Schweden Demokraten und das haben sie
genau auch 2023 in Spanien sofort die
Union in Europa die Christdemokraten die
EVP wird sich entscheiden müssen ob sie
tatsächlich diese Wertegemeinschaft die
uns hier verbindet tatsächlich
verteidigt oder ob sie aus Partei
taktischen Gründen mit rechtsradikalen
und Rechtsextremisten die mit der AFD in
der Fraktion des Europäischen Parlaments
sind paktiert oder nicht genau darum
wird es gehen und wo die SPD steht wo
diese Koalition steht mit Olaf Scholz
mit dem Finanzminister Lindner mit
Harbeck und mit bärbock das ist völlig
klar und deshalb werden wir das auch
genauso hinbekommen vielen Dank
Axel Schiefer 70 Jahre alt 1994 bis 99
Mitglied im Europäischen Parlament seit
2002 hier im Deutschen Bundestag und der
Bundeskanzler hat wirklich bis zum
Schluss ausgehart mit einem gewissen
Lächeln auf den Lippen verlässt er jetzt
hier den Plenarsaal sehr schön
eingefangen wir sind allerdings nur noch
von hinten er hat einen wirkliches
Lächeln auf den Lippen ich glaube über
die Rede seines Parteifreundes Axel
Schäfer und um 15 Uhr wie gesagt beginnt
der Europäische Rat in Brüssel und da
Berlin ja durchaus nicht so weit weg ist
von Brüssel da wird es der Bundeskanzler
auch noch rechtzeitig schaffen aber
bemerkenswert ist es schon dass wir dich
an der Stelle noch mal sagen an so einem
Tag hier die gesamte Debatte sitzen zu
bleiben das hat auch nicht jeder
Vorgänger oder Vorgängerin von ihm so
getan